دبابات فرنسيه خفيفه ستسلمها باريس لكيف
هي سابقه من نوعها اعلنت عنها رئاسه
الفرنسيه بعد ان كانت المساعدات العسكريه
الغربيه
تقتصر على دبابات سوفياتيه الصنع
ان الرئيس رغبه بزياده المساعده العسكريه
المقدمه لكيف من خلال الموافقه على
تسليمها دبابات خفيفه وهذه هي المره
الاولى التي ستتزود فيها القوه الركرانيه
بدبابات غربيه تصميم
لكن فرنسا لا تعتزم في الوقت الراهن تزويد
الجيش الاوكراني بدبابات ثقيله التي يصل
مدام دفعها الى اربعه الاف متر الرئيس
الاوكراني فولوزيلنسكي الذي يكثف العمل مع
شركائه الغربيين للحصول على عتاد مماثل
شكر الرئيس الفرنسي على قراره تزويد بلاده
بهذه الدبابات الخفيفه
لاوكرانيا
وباريس متوسطه
الاخرى من المركبات المدرعه لمساعده
القوات الاوكرانيه على تعزيز قدراتها في
الوقت الذي ستقدم فيه باريس لكيف في
الايام المقبله 63 مولدا كهربائيا عاليا
الجهد لتلبيه الاحتياجات العاجله
لاوكرانيا التي تضررت بنيتها التحتيه
للطاقه بشكل كبير بسبب ضربات الروسيه
المتوسطه